oh but them I still back on my head what
you doing that there hello everybody my
name is prestige and this is another
episode of my divine RPG survival let's
play strap against I just thought there
were way too many starters to that this
is just a plan i'm playing with mod
called divine RPG and i'm just playing
minecraft its survival let's play so i
hope you guys enjoying and this episode
which i'm up 10 might be 10 might be
loving might be now i might be 12 odd oh
this episode we're going to be building
a tiny little fisherman's cabin right
away but if he he wait i get some dirt
one second Nick dirt and I'm very sorry
very sorry guys that if there's any lag
if they're sending the leg goes I took
place okay because there is lag because
i am trying to uh i'm actually exporting
to other divine rpgs at the moments
because i'm i'm gonna be gone for two
weeks as I said and the other ones and
if this should come out during the time
that I'm away so I like pre-recorded and
I really don't have much time to do it
since it is like 11am and I my pet mat
peoples in the house is sleeping so yeah
so let's just let's just make us look
all nice and stuff yeah looking looking
nice as usually is nice so just place
this all around cover up that coal but I
don't need you cold and place you and I
think that's pretty good yeah I can get
up over he also yeah i'm going to make
it add another brick so we're going to
make this just a edge just because we
wants it to be the this is going to be
the mysterious fish in place so i think
that is even wool sighs uh-huh so let's
start to make it so it's going to have
one area like right here that you can
lick out in fish ads so I'm probably one
problem you've never content
near the fence on the guy vania offense
many go to the nether of the fortress so
far away I will see what happens um like
I get all fancy like like boom boom boom
maybe this will be like that yet we'll
just to where did you like that and then
like that like that it's gonna be quite
a small Shack like this and this is good
and then the roof is going to be like
that we're gonna need more of these
definitely definitely boop boop boop Oh
mr. poop I'm just gonna go make more
than right now oh that's some lag again
guys I'm really sorry I never I hate
watching videos with lag so I'm
apologizing for the lag it is in my
video Hey oh dang a problem you can be
enough but i do not know what I wanted
this could be super tiny it can make it
bigger that is it is really really small
arm hmm me want to expand it out a pit
can I want to make it symmetrical though
let's make okay so let's make that like
an outpost to it and then let's i don't
know like that like that looks good i
like that corner like it like what they
do the stairs um so just like that
like this my Beach magdy let's to give
you some more space i don't think i've
got much more nether brick left I'm
gonna have enough I was going to make
this super tiny I can chop this down a
bit i think it was like let's let's me
saving like one space is just kind of
look cool so I'm place like that upset
some light up in here um just deciding
on what to do there's obviously gonna
break down my door bro bro oh stop it
bro well I miss Braham warning me bro
bro told you I didn't listen he didn't
listen then i can destroy this i really
have no idea what i'm doing here mmm and
this would be like this then
I've slabs yeah yeah yeah yeah like yeah
like like once I gonna say I guess I got
this like yeah like yeah like yeah also
good here gives you a little more
d'accord really it really does it limits
you cuddly oh I thought it's quite tiny
but it looks kind of cool also ones like
all I'm out of stairs I'm going to do
says I I need to sit as well I don't
think i need this corner piece that was
corrected not need a corner piece he's
here he's here mmm yeah I got to decide
what I want to do with these stairs
decisions decisions you see like a piece
like I don't do it I did not mean to do
that come on they work with me work with
my bro Oh sleep at okay do not want to
place that one like that though just
look at that
mm-hmm or I could just get rid of them I
said why I keep doing that so I'm gonna
throw 40 I just put it like that don't
get rid it the whole problem let it back
boom
so what does it look like this looks
very interesting that's a good give the
video said settings a little better
short legit mmm um you know I'm gonna
destroy the back I wanted to be like a
small little thing determined him with a
spider bad bad should know not to pick a
fight with me spider did so many of your
brethren with this divine sword I just
wanted to be a shack so it was getting
to uncheck like I want to keep this
Shack eNOS of it um I'll expand it out a
bit though oh my freaking gosh no no I'm
not it's not even equipped not even if
there anymore just annoying good now
they're annoying creepers I'm completely
like safe from them like they can't even
hurt me through the armor I've and
they're still annoying still annoying
mm-hmm you just expand out like
like that boop boop yes oh that looks
good let's see what I should do with
this one up um I could be like stairs to
did not mean to Wow spider did you not
just see me killing a brother dude dude
you you get hurt when you hit me like
why did you pick a fight with somebody
that you get hurt when you hit them oh
I'll try that looks good it's a nice
Shack I like there's no way in but
suddenly shy I got some room and go
fishing yeah like the shack is in a
shack nice Oh first all you just thought
I'd forgot about the floor didn't you
did all right now what material you guys
think I should make that out of I know
why I'm asking this I'm gonna put it in
the same video you guys in here you guys
since i'll tell me so listen obviously
Oh make it another rap you're getting
stone bricks would complement it well
let's try stone bricks and let's also
try bricks we had another brick if stone
brick and we have birth the brick the
brick is brick and cuts in food I don't
care that's honest I'm food bro not even
yeah we'll definitely have view more
stuff and also when the grass comes in
this will look better adore it trust me
alright so this is how so that looks
pretty good I like that now let's try it
with brick
none ah I'm not too sure about the brick
hmm I do kind of like the brick I think
I like the stone brick more also if i'm
going to have put the holiday up at the
initiative away I'm gonna go with some
brick stop break it is that is if you
guys tell me if most you guys like the
brick / stone brick panel look I can
change it but let's run over here with
the immense lag that we're getting and
throw this stuff in there it's really
not organization is gone out the window
up let's go to work on this over here so
i cant want more space if you do that
then I see if I break it I oh I just
want to break the lower one so let's do
that and that's oh no called a prime not
placing that me blocks I think that'd be
good space go fishing I think I'll make
a door and then
or can I make another bird gate fence
don't think I can be a pleasure can all
right well oh well oh well well we're
gonna make ourselves a deal of what I
yes we'll make ourselves like door um
and a chest boom boom boom boom boom
boom and let's go get some strength to
make yourselves like fishing rod like to
[ __ ] too stringy should be good and my
36 should suffice and we have ourselves
a fishing rod also on the back let's
place the door i legit legit too legit
to quit chest a fishing rod now see it
anytime we want to go out here you just
talked about yeah we got to do a better
torch scene um I'll do torches in the
back like this the Shan ya sea fishing
is peaceful on Bob oh I i think i had
done it so i can't you can buy our
napkin Bob come on let's go fish let's
go come on let's go fish you're nothing
on this
bro let's go come on fish your me 11
come on let's go outside in the water
come on fishing rod in my fishing shack
let's go come on you can't even touch
this come on fish yeah let's go you me
all what is that that wasn't bad don't
bubbles don't know if no fishy no fish
oh yeah screw this fishing is so
aggravating all right then for the
outside I put two over here and 22 what
the heck okis of the stairs do right
there are my fishing place looks cool do
I look better once I like oh how much
glitz oh I'm just like mumbling over
everything all right guys I'm gonna end
up here I hope you enjoyed this video I
do I really do I hope you all have a
wonderful day and if you got the in this
video I was think if you make it to all
the way to the end of the videos person
one of these long ones make sure you
give it a little favorite like rake the
favorite like the rate comment or
subscribe it really appreciate it and
I'll see you all later my name's
prestige peace